[Musica]
[Applauso]
mare di erba dakar a corinne a cracovia
in sella due cavalli mongoli 9000 km 5
100 giorni 2 selle e un telo tenda e
centinaia di persone incontrate che
hanno reso possibile avanzare davvero al
sicuro
1241 cracovia una tromba destra
l'allarme i tartari sono alle porte un
arciere mongolo colpisce il trombettiere
alla gola i mongoli guidati da batman
entrano in città
distruggono tutto vanno avanti ma a
breve si ritirano un trombettiere sulla
torre meridionale della basilica di
santa maria suona tuttora ad ogni ora
una musica che si interrompe prima di
finire in ricordo di quel remoto
scampato pericolo in quella piazza è
nata e si è compiuta
l'idea di questa impresa in un istante
ho immaginato tutte queste genti
arrivare da est in sella ai loro cavalli
in un modo così leggiadro che qui non si
era mai visto distruggendo però tutto
quello che incontravano sul loro cammino
è del ostruiva è stato possibile
compiere questo viaggio per la guerra
come rifarlo per la pace finalmente
il 10 di giugno dell'anno scorso o
stretti sottopancia sono salita in sella
e mi sono presentata di fronte al
municipio di karakuri che adesso è una
piccola cittadina poco più di un
villaggio ma era l'antica capitale della
mongolia ii e bat l'attuale sindaco mi
ha affidato una freccia costruita ora
come allora da portare legata alla sera
di un piccolo cavallo mongolo pronto ad
affrontare ogni step a scegliere
il mongolo significa dritto è un piccolo
cavallo nero come il carbone voglia di
vivere ciuffo ribelle come i cosacchi
che abbiamo incontrato sul don custode
volano forte faccia buona ha protetto il
viaggio dalle anomalie
loro sono i cavalli con cui ho potuto
salpare verso il mare di erba delle
steppe dell'eurasia to move rubat
è un arciere mongolo ha vinto anche in
cambio lamba tor conosci la disciplina
nel modo più tradizionale e costruisce
da sé i suoi archi e le sue frecce sale
sulle montagne da cui è dovuto venir via
per andare a vivere nella capitale ma
lassù trova corna legno zoccoli tendini
e piume di aquila che poi porta nel suo
appartamento in città in una delle
centinaia di condomini sovietici tutti
identici di cui è disseminata fa
stagionare quello che deve stagionare
cuoce quello che deve cuocere modella
quello che deve prendere una forma
quando l'ho conosciuto erano solo più in
quattro gli artigiani che nella mongolia
est esterna costruivano ancora archi e
frecce in modo tradizionale
adesso sono di più perché lui ha
insegnato a molte persone
una delle sue frecce e quella che è
partita verso la polonia legata alla
sella decidere l'asta era dritta
perfetta quando siamo partiti gli urti
del viaggio
l'hanno un po mancata la prima della
coda era tagliata in modo da calibrarne
perfettamente la traiettoria ma un cane
giocando in un bivacco durante il tratto
mongolo me l'aveva
la rosicchiata e non era più come prima
la punta era un'antica punta di bronzo
che un conoscente di bath moore aveva
trovato con il metal detector identica a
quelle che ho visto nei musei
era tutto ossidata quando sono partita
ma le persone lungo la strada notavano
la freccia mi chiedevano di vederla e di
toccarla
e a forza di sentire tutte quelle mani
addosso questa punta che era così verde
sembrava qualcosa di morto ed è tornata
a scintillare quando volevano vedere la
freccia le persone facevano proprio
anche il messaggio che stavo portando
verso ovest e in quel momento ai loro
occhi
io non ero più una persona ma un'idea
che aveva bisogno di essere protetta e
sostenuta in qualche modo ma mentre
trasportava un'idea ero anche una
persona e mi sono trovato ad
attraversare vaste aree in cui non c'era
nessuno
i cavalli trasportavano tutto il
necessario per poter avanzare in
autonomia per giorni non saprei
scegliere tra i bivacchi passati
sperduti in mezzo alle montagne e quelli
vicino gli accampamenti o ai villaggi in
ogni caso mi è sempre sembrato di essere
ospite la mia casa era un pelo di tre
metri per tre
tirato tra alberi pali pietre o quello
che trovavo intorno cielo e steppa e due
corde lunghe una dozzina di metri
vincolate a due soli di picchetti
intorno a cui pascolavano i cavalli il
momento in cui il caffè esce dalla
caffettiera e lascia il suo odore è
diventato un segnale anche per loro lo
sanno che nel giro di poco chiudere
l'ultima cerniera e sarà ora di
rimettersi in pista per andare da
un'altra parte coperta sottosella sella
bisacce musetti borracce e poi 6 7 8 9
ore giornaliere di marcia ricerca di
quello che serve per andare avanti che
può essere la spesa per me piuttosto che
la pietanza per i cavalli e ricerca del
posto del campo di nuovo il bivacco quei
confortevoli 5 metri quadri in cui
sentirmi a casa in mentre i cavalli
pascolano intorno sereni per prima
ho attraversato la mongolia e volevo
incontrare la gente senza conoscere la
lingua per fortuna azar lég
al quinto giorno di marcia ho conosciuto
e ne guida a cavallo che però non poteva
venire con me perché era alta stagione
per le guida cavallo che non aveva
momenti per sganciarsi però lui mi ha
donato un taccuino foderato di cuoio che
era arrivato nelle sue mani di mano in
mano da un viaggiatore all'altro passo
facendo il giro del mondo era ancora
bianco dopo anni che girava per il mondo
e due però lo ha sporcato per la prima
volta scrivendo con queste due pagine
l'intento del mio progetto in mongolo e
aveva aggiunto questa donna sta
compiendo questo viaggio per tutti
coloro che amano i cavalli
se anche tu ami cavalli devi aiutarla e
io mi sono trovata con in mano un
passepartout su cupo su cui poi tutti i
mongoli che ho incontrato hanno aggiunto
le loro cose per per dire anche loro la
loro ma l'hanno scritta il mondo e
quindi devo ancora farmele tradurre un
altro ostacolo altrettanto
insormontabile quanto la comunicazione
con i mongoli è stato attraversare la
russia d inverno per avanzare in questa
stagione avevo un sistema che però mi
faceva perdere moltissimo tempo e andavo
pianissimo perché ovviamente prima di
tutto dovevo salvaguardare il fatto che
i cavalli dovevano mangiare e io non
dovevo morire di freddo prima di far
morire di freddo quei due credo che ce
ne voglia una sera sono stata ospite di
roman veterinario di quella che possiamo
chiamare l'azienda sanitaria locale di
rigore
ata monday cosa che di questo paese lui
ha comunicato la mia storia alla radio
dei cosacchi che da quel giorno sono
sempre stati informati sulla mia
posizione e hanno fatto il possibile per
adoperarsi a farmi avanzare in sicurezza
facendomi trovare fenu avena per i
capperi cavalli e acqua liquida tutti i
giorni ma poi mi venivano incontro si
assicuravano che lungo la strada non mi
capitasse niente e in un giorno che
c'era bufera e cielo e terra erano
confusi e talmente confusi che non
sapevo se stavo camminando con la testa
su la testa in giù mi son venuti
incontro in macchina e quando ho visto
quei due fari che arrivavano in 40
centimetri di polvere ho saputo che
erano loro prima di vederli e poi questo
è cresciuto dalla macchina aveva il
berretto dei cosacchi che forse si è
visto nelle foto una fascia di pelo con
una croce gialla il camporosso sulla
testa quello è il colore dei cosacchi
del don
loro l'hanno scortata per oltre 1500 per
quasi 1.500 km finché non ho
attraversato un ponte e dall'altra parte
del fiume di cosacchi non ce n'erano più
ma ormai era primavera avanti avanti
avanti ed è arrivata l'estate abbiamo
passato la frontiera e siamo scesi in
polonia è dappertutto iniziavano a
chiedermi ma cracovia
c'è qualcuno che aspetta questa freccia
io avevo molta paura di questa cosa
perché avevo scritto alla basilica di
santa maria
ma nessuno mi aveva risposto e così non
potevo fare niente altro che andare
avanti per scoprire come sarebbe andata
a finire ma non lo sapevo
la seconda notte che ho passato in
polonia però mi sono fermata cras lo
gruda che un posto talmente piccolo che
pensare che io per caso sia finita lì è
ai limiti della magia
lì ho conosciuto zbigniew benedicto
beach professore di antropologia
dell'università di bar savia che
quando ha saputo la mia storia ha fatto
il possibile perché la missione siri si
compisse al cento per cento
prima ha avvisato il museo di cracovia
poi il comune e poi finalmente è
arrivato a parlare con i pompieri che
anche per lui è stato difficile sono i
pompieri che suonano la tromba lassù
e così quando sono arrivata cracovia
avevo veramente il permesso di accam
parmi alla buona il pascolo della città
praticamente in centro la città di
cracovia
c'è un enorme prateria che un lascito di
una nobildonna partita in pellegrinaggio
per il santo sepolcro e mai più
ritornata che è sempre stato un prato li
ho montato il mio telo come sempre con i
cavalli intorno come se fossi in mezzo
alla steppa
ma nel mattino in due chilometri sono
arrivate alla porta di san floriano
scortate dalla polizia che mi
accompagnava e laggiù c'era un sacco di
gente
la porta di san floriano e quella
settentrionale della città la stessa da
cui sono entrati i mongoli san floriano
è il patrono dei pompieri ma anche della
città di cracovia i mongoli sono passati
da lì è anche noi abbiamo percorso la
via fino in piazza con tutto questo
corteo di gente dalla porta e la cenere
dell'altra ed era stata organizzata una
grande festa in cui il sindaco della
città mi ha accolta a lui ho dato la
freccia che adesso è stata portata dai
pompieri nella torre da cui viene
suonato lei now questa musica che si
interrompe sembra che questo mondo
voglia farci parlare sempre al futuro
la dimensione del progetto prevale sulla
memoria passato e futuro sono entrambi
necessari per costruire qualcosa di
nuovo con la coscienza di ciò che già
esiste ma il presente
che è sempre comunque davanti a noi il
momento su cui possiamo davvero agire la
mia cavalla isotta lalinga con cui ho
fatto tutti i viaggi prima di questo mi
aveva insegnato a fare una cosa per
volta
un passo dopo l'altro a non pensare mai
a dove stavo andando ad andare da quella
parte
lungo tutta questa strada sapevo che
ogni giorno nella basilica di santa
maria un trombettiere sul navona musica
e si interrompeva sempre nello stesso
punto
questa musica si chiama è in sé
significa sentinella grazie
[Applauso]